[Musique]
compliqué cela comme question non vous
allez faire chanter la reine des neiges
c'est quoi je suis pas du tout mais
alors pas du tout football tous les deux
vont bien ensemble
quand on est dans l'hémicycle en tout
cas ces lignes on peut sans aucun doute
[Musique]
je ne comprends rien ou règle du hors
jeu agen fait pour le théâtre du dîner
de cons choucroute sans aucun doute
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien les deux
c'est toujours pas compris l'intérêt de
twitter s'exprimer en 140 caractères
faire de la politique
nous ferons part axé incontournable du
tronc je suis assez classique finalement
[Musique]
partagé je suis curieux et l'excès au
évidemment
[Musique]
d'armes assez plat
christian jacob sans aucun doute parce
que c'est le président parce que c'est
un homme de valeur parce que c'est un
homme de parole parce que c'est un homme
de terrain et parce qu'en plus c'est un
type sympa le général de gaulle la
droiture sens de l'état salon
l'agriculture n'a eu que mac os à fuir
c'est pas toujours l'idéal
notre filière cristalline c'est de l'eau
du robinet ayant bâti des recettes l'eau
minérale c'est quand même autre chose
[Musique]
aux flammes a cure comme on dit chez moi
les deux j'ai la chance de ne pas dormir
beaucoup disent trop un bon moment sympa
à partager la marseillaise de rouget de
lisle écrite à strasbourg pour moi c'est
mieux qu'au vite mais j'ai pas compris
pourquoi on a mis là si on a commencé
par tous de dire le nom de je ne
supporte plus ce confinement mais je
crois comme tout le monde donc confiture
le matin celle de ma maman
strasbourg la plus belle et la plus
grande des cathédrales gothiques
je pense qu'il faut pouvoir être les 2 2
apporte à notre regard sur le quotidien
et je pense qu'on peut pas être l'un
sans avoir été l'autre on peut pas être
députés sans avoir été mais aujourd'hui
je suis député
[Musique]